[Music]
hello everyone and welcome to tonight's
episode of beginner breakdown my name is
Alex Fuller and I'm excited to be
talking with you about our topic tonight
which is end games we haven't done end
games in a little while
um and it's always good to revisit
because they come up quite frequently
and it's important to be precise and
we're going to specifically be talking
about King safety uh or sorry uh the
opposite of King safety really is active
Kings how do we use our King because you
know in the opening in the middle game
it's really imperative that we keep the
king quite safe tucked away hidden from
our opponent's pieces often we want to
Castle quite early in order to again
avoid any attacks or breaking open of
the center
but in the end game is when that all
changes in order to properly win most
end games your King has to become an
active piece
um and I see someone in the chat
invested in someone's endgame course
highly recommend uh very very good we're
going to be talking about actually uh
some stuff from Selman that I stole from
a different book but
um to start let's just take a look at
this famous end game that's actually
really instructive I've looked at it in
previous lectures but it holds value
even still and is relevant in a lot of
different ways so this is the position
this was from a game in 1905 of uh
Marshall and chagoran
and it is black to move and find kind of
the best plan so if you want to suggest
a move that's fine but it's more
important to understand what the right
plan is for black because it's easy to
get a little bit distracted in this
position and go astray so if you had
black here
taking a look at everything going on in
the position it's equal material
slightly imbalanced in the placement
right we have two pawns on this side
against one but white has a passed on on
D4
and perhaps our Rook is slightly more
active
maybe black or White's King is against
slightly more active so the question is
how should we continue here to make
progress
and as always if you are watching from
home uh live feel free to put a comment
here in the twitch chat and we can
discuss the ideas so twm in the chat
Rook C3 jumps out but keep looking so
yeah good idea to keep looking it is a
forcing move right Rook C3 is check and
it does pick up this hanging Pawn on A3
so theoretically after white moves we
would pick up a pawn so the question is
is that the best plan for black why or
why not
We Believe
so my thought here is actually when I
first looked at this Rook see through
was the move I wanted to play as well
but Rook C3
is slightly problematic yet the past
Pawn is a bit of a concern because if we
play Rook C free check let's say King
moves forward we take
two problems one
White's King is more activated they
could potentially even play King D5 and
try and guard guide this Pawn home but
also our Rook has abandoned this open
file and now maybe white has a way to
invade with Rook to C2 uh is that worth
this Rook Pawn I mean we have two nice
pawns over here but it's hard to say
it's certainly going to be more
imbalanced and a bit scarier kind of a
double-edged position
the move that was found in the game by
shogoren was actually to play King E6
ignoring the fact that we can just win a
pawn which is kind of crazy at first
right we're gonna not win a pawn in the
end game
but when you see the idea it all becomes
really clear
okay so we're going to advance the king
and we would really like to just play
King to D5 and try and take this Pawn so
uh White plays the move Rook B3
preventing us from getting away with
this idea we already had now we can no
longer win the pawn
but we're quite happy here to play King
to D5
and now white is forced to defend this
Pawn which he does with Rook to D3
and it seems like okay well we could
have won a pawn but we didn't so what
was the point of all of this
well now that our King is more active
and our Rook is again very active and
when I talk about a piece being active I
mean it's controlling a lot of relevant
squares it has the option to move to
important places
this Rook if it really needed to it
could jump in and invade on the second
rank it could drop back to defend if it
really had to it can come out to a four
perhaps we've got a lot of options with
this piece
compare that to White's Rook which looks
very nice and centralized but actually
is quite stuck if it leaves this uh this
rank the third rank then we can always
come back with our idea of Rook C3 check
and again try and pick up this Pawn
and if it leaves this file well now
we're just picking up this Pawn on D4 so
The Rook is actually really
cramped it needs to stay where it is and
it's not an active piece at all and
because of that likewise this King right
our King is looking to press forward and
keep charging through and White's King
is now stuck on the defense
and black found that in this position
because these pieces are not nearly as
active or aggressive and our pieces are
taking the initiative that we could
actually start to stall our opponent out
so we should go in here played F5
Marshall played Pawn to H3 because
there's not really anything else to do
right if you push this Pawn we'll just
take it again you can't move this Rook
be for one of these two reasons and you
can't push this Pawn now with F5 or
we'll take it here so the only real move
is to just play this Pawn but chagorn is
very happy to just play the waiting game
H5 and in the game King E2 was played
but if white continues to try and stall
we have just enough waiting moves we
could even continue with A5 if we needed
more
and white is just going to run out of
moves So eventually you are going to
have to do something give something up
and there's not really a good way to do
that King E2 was selected in the game in
order to kind of minimize these
casualties
Rook takes and now white does not have
to make a trade of Rooks which is very
important if you're in an end game you
want to keep it as complex as possible
so trying to keep the advantage by
having your Rook able to create counter
play perhaps was what happened in the
game I believe shagorn went on to still
win but this was the idea from
Marshall's side had he instead moved the
Rook
this again does not really help anything
so say you drop the Rook back as we said
this is going to allow Rook to C3 and
even though you can play Rook to D3 and
block and defend well now that we're
trading the Rooks off the board this
simplified end game should be quite
simple for black to win we're just going
to advance our pawns we have a 2V1
majority here on the uh the queen side
and there's not really anything light
can do let's say King C3 we can even
sacrifice this extra Pawn in order to
win this Pawn here in the center and
we're just going to maneuver our King
eat up whites extra pawns and very
easily promote and win the game
so this is a simple example uh but it
illustrates a very important point that
the king needs to be an active piece in
the end game even sometimes at the cost
of material right if you play Rook C3
here you pick up a pawn but is that
really worth it when our opponent gets
so much active counter play probably not
now now that we have the idea of how
importantly active King is there's two
Maneuvers and types of kind of
positional ideas with end games and with
a king that are both incredibly
important to understand
uh their opposition and kind of the
outflanking maneuver so we're going to
start with opposition
for a lot of these examples I'm going to
have a pawn somewhere on the board
unless I say it's important just ignore
it because otherwise I can't move the
Kings it will treat it like it's a
stalemate or something so ignore this
Pawn the idea here we want to look at is
opposition with the Kings and this is
just the most basic form it's just
called direct opposition
both Kings would like to advance forward
right black would like to move towards
our side of the board we would like to
move towards their side of the board and
try and gain ground make progress in the
position but we have moved into this
position where there is one square
directly between us we are facing each
other and because of that this is called
opposition each King is controlling
these three squares and when you are in
opposition the person who has to move
out of the way is the one who's in a
worse shape because they have to concede
some ground
so for instance in this position if it
is black to move then they're going to
have to step to one of these two sides
say King to E6 allowing us to make
forward progress
King to C6 would do the opposite
and if it was our turn to move we would
obviously have to move out of the way
and they would do the same so this is
direct opposition you can also have
opposition that is indirect this is
sometimes called diagonal opposition as
well and it's the same type of idea it's
just now the Kings have a straight line
in between them facing each other with
one square where um
it's just a diagonal instead of a
vertical or horizontal line that they
are facing on and usually this is going
to transpose right so say again it's
black to move they are the ones who if
we have the opposition and they have to
move then we are going to make progress
if they move down we can make progress
this way
if they go to the side we can make
progress this way right creating a
direct opposition that is again going to
let us break through
um quick aside we have a question from
the chat uh at the end of our session
London Carl Khan which end games come up
most I know where to focus on Game Study
it's a good question let me come back to
that at the end and see if I can give
you some kind of answer
but I want to continue with the
definitions right now okay so we have
direct and indirect opposition
and now we want to talk about something
that's probably the the next level up
it's even maybe potentially more
important
when the two kings are very far apart
it seems hard to know who is going to
have opposition if they are to approach
each other
because remember whichever side has
opposition is the one that can make
progress and if you don't have
opposition you're going to be forced out
of the way
so we can use the idea of distant
opposition to determine who is going to
have that in this position
the rule we like to follow to figure out
who it's going to have opposition is
this
whoever is the person who moves with an
odd number of squares between the Kings
does not have opposition or
alternatively whoever moves when there
is an even number of squares between the
Kings does have opposition so let's take
a look at what I mean in this position
it's white to move and how many squares
are there between these two Kinks well
there's eight ranks or eight ranks on
the board and we are occupying two of
them so mathematically there's six
which is an even number and we're the
one moving so if there's an even number
that means we have the opposition
now it's Black's turn to move and
there's an odd number of squares we've
just taken one away so there's only five
in between us which means uh that we
have the opposition still because again
they have an odd number and they have to
move and we'll see if both sides walk
towards each other
this is how it works out we make it to
D4 and have a direct opposition where
black has to move out of the way
and we can make progress in the position
this is going to be the same if it's on
a diagonal so we'll count the number of
squares in between one two three four
five six and because it's let's say in
this case it's white to move
with an even number when we make the
move it is still going to be us with
opposition when the two kings meet in
the center
okay this is again an indirect
opposition or a diagonal opposition that
could transpose to a direct quite
naturally
so this seems pretty simple right it's
not too hard to understand how the kings
are go which one is going to have
opposition when they interact
um when they're in a straight line right
when it's in a either a file or a
diagonal
this becomes a little trickier
when they fail to connect in such a
simplistic way
so let's take a look at this example
again ignore our Pawn here on H2
in this type of situation
we want to figure out with white to move
whether or not we're going to be able to
take the opposition or maintain the
opposition
um
and what that looks like and generally
the rule of thumb is when you're in this
type of situation
in order to uh to gain opposition or
maintain opposition
you want to step onto a square
of the same color as your opponent's
king so take a look at this if we go
King to A2
notice how
both the white and black king aren't a
light square and we could kind of
Imagine a box connecting the two
what this tells us is if we're able to
take a square of that color that we will
have the opposition here when we make
that move
so let's say black continues King to f8
the move we need to play here
is King to B2 continuing that square
if they come back
then we do the same thing right we want
to stay on that same kind of color
complex
and eventually this works its way out no
matter where they go
we're going to keep following in this
kind of color pattern and see how
eventually we end up here with our
indirect opposition which again can very
easily transpose to direct opposition
and there's lots of deviations that can
happen here but for example if King to
E7 in this beginning then instead of
going to somewhere else we would just go
to B2 right and it's the same type of
deal or if in this position instead of
playing King back to E8 let's say black
goes King to F7
here we can go King to B3
and we have this same light squared
color complex that we are following them
on eventually we will make indirect
opposition or direct opposition when we
get close enough
okay
One More Concept so this is really the
basics of opposition now we're going to
talk about out flanking and then we're
going to explain why is this all
relevant this seems so unimportant but
we're going to get there
out flanking is a really simple but very
useful technique we've already seen it a
little bit but I haven't really
explained it but it's basically a way to
make progress and reach critical squares
in a position where otherwise you
couldn't
in order to do this we're often going to
have to give up opposition but we can
still move our way into the key squares
opposition is important but it's only
going to be a means to an end and we're
going to see that as we go so in this
example this is actually kind of a
really interesting puzzle
it is white to move and our goal again
Let's ignore this Pawn pretend the pawn
on H2 is not there our goal is to reach
one of these two squares f8 or h8 it
doesn't matter which one Black's goal is
to stop us from doing so
if we can make our King touch one of
those squares we win this puzzle and if
black can stop us then they will succeed
in winning the puzzle the question is
can we do it and how
and the first thing to note is we're
probably going to need opposition and
here's what I mean if we just walk
towards this Square
by the direct approach our opponent can
take opposition
and as long as they have opposition in
this way
we can never actually move forward
right wherever we go if we step back
they can follow us
and wherever we go we're always the one
conceding space they're just going to
mirror whatever move we play until we're
stuck on the back Rank and just moving
around and they're going to move and
just copy us and cut us off
so if we give our opponent opposition
too early they can just cut us off from
this whole half of the board
foreign
so what can we do instead how do we take
the opposition in this position keep in
mind kind of the rules we looked at for
opposition and see what you can come up
with here
what should we do
and again if you're in the chat or in
person and have suggestions feel free to
throw them out there so Susie in the
chat suggesting King A2 right like we
just saw if we count the number of
squares in between two kings in a
straight line
uh we have six if it's even then we can
move forward in that direction and
maintain opposition
so King to A2 okay
now black to move and they're going to
play very tricky if they just like move
forward then we already know it's going
to happen whether they move forward this
way or this way
then we already know we're just going to
move forward and we're going to take
opposition and force them out of the way
so that's not going to be helpful
for them
so instead black plays the really tricky
move King to B8
now why is this so tricky well again
black is laying a trap here and hoping
we give up our oppositional advantage
so what can we do
here
okay so I'm suggesting going to B1
what do we think about that King to B1
is that the move we need to play
again our objective here is to reach
one of these two squares
some suggesting B2 some saying A3
yeah so let's talk about some of these
ideas so King B1
is actually not going to work
and it's for the same reason as before
now it's Black starting to move but they
have gained distant opposition they're
moving when we're in a straight line and
there's an even number of spaces between
us
so they can just step forward and we're
going to be in serious trouble here
if we try and move forward now they're
the ones who can just go and again now
they can stall us out
so we cannot go to B1
if we go to uh to B3 let's say
then again how many squares are between
us now there are uh one two three four
squares in between us and Black's the
one moving so an even number when they
move means that they're going to have
opposition
if we go to A3 and now A3 is a really
interesting move
it's sort of trying to outflank but
we'll get to that more in a second it's
just a little too early for this
um they can just play something like
King to A7 and again create this
opposition right we have to move and
there's an odd number of squares which
means we're going to be losing
opposition
so instead the only way to make progress
here is to play King to B2
we want there to still be this odd
number when it's their turn to move of
squares between us and Them
so we keep the opposition but also
notice that our goal here is to reach f8
or h8 so we need to make progress in two
directions this way and this way
and right now we're making progress this
way we're going to do that first
again if black here tries anything funny
if they just try and move forwards we
already know we have the opposition so
we're just now making progress in both
directions this way and this way
so the best move for black is to
actually play King to C8 and we're gonna
keep doing this dance right the same
thing is going to be true every time if
we move forward we're going to give them
opposition
so we need to keep sliding this way
slowly making progress even though it
doesn't feel like it because we need to
get to this side of the board where we
can come and attack these two squares
okay so we're going to continue this
song and dance all the way down the
board
until we get to this really critical
Square in G2
again this ignore this punt
because now black has a choice
they can go to h8 continuing in the line
or they can go to f8
but either Square they're conceding
something so for example if they go to
f8
we can now out flank we will give them
opposition
but that's not going to matter very soon
we will go King to H3 and our goal is
now here they can take opposition this
way and keep our King from this whole
side of the board
but if we have identified a key square
that we need to get to they're going to
have a really hard time stopping us
and the same is true if they go to h8
where would we go now to start out
flanking them in this case we would go
to F3
and here's why
if
they try and hold on to this opposition
right they're going to do the same thing
we did they step into this light Square
to make this kind of box between the two
kings and they do get opposition
we're going to move forward and they can
take indirect opposition
and now direct opposition
but notice what they're keeping us out
from they're keeping us from getting
over to this row
they are not keeping us from getting
here and now they actually can't stop us
even though they have opposition we
still make it to our key Square
so the idea about flanking is we're
sometimes willing to give up opposition
in order to get our King where it needs
to go
this will become really relevant later
when we talk about Pawn promotion
okay so instead if they play just
something like King to G7
right we already know uh if they play
King H7 and just go this way we're just
going to March our way down so we need
to try and stop us so King to G7 seems
to make sense
but now
what should we do
how should we continue to make progress
any suggestions for us
again we want to touch one of these two
squares if we touch one of those squares
we win the game
yes Susie again in the chat precisely
King to G3
putting an odd number of squares between
our King and their King in a straight
line when it is their turn to move
because now if they move towards us
we just take opposition and we're going
to force them away
we can start to advance our way in
but let's not get ahead of ourselves
um this is why they can't play King to
G8 because if they play King to G8 where
do we go to keep an odd number of
squares between R king and their King we
go right forward to G4 so we're making
progress slightly faster
so King to G7 and we play King to G3
critical here that we don't move forward
too quickly again right if we play King
to G4 right now they're just going to
take opposition and now with opposition
they do bar us from this side of the
board
so instead King to G3
and again black has a bunch of moves
they can play here but probably the
trickiest is King to F7
trying to again bait us into making a
mistake if we step forward anywhere
they're going to take opposition except
on H4
because now it's the same thing we just
looked at
we're giving up opposition if you play
King to F6 you're getting opposition
but you cannot keep us from this Square
you either have to give it back up in
which case we still hold on to
opposition
or you keep it and you can't stop us
so instead King to G6 but now it's
already too late we just take direct
opposition on G4
and the King slowly has to work its way
back
we will continue to outflank our
opponent giving them opposition but
they're not able to stop us from getting
to this key Square
so they instead go back we take
opposition again and this dance
continues until eventually
they have to pick
are they going to stop us from coming to
H7 and h8 or are they going to stop us
from coming to F7 and f8 and they cannot
stop both
so we will force our weight to touch one
of those squares
now this puzzle is again not something
that would be immediately obvious how
it's relevant to a game of chess where
we're just running the kings around and
trying to touch different squares on the
board but it actually becomes very very
apparent where this is valuable when we
think about Pawn promotion
so I've talked about promoting ponds at
different points in uh this beginner
breakdown series but it's always
something so important and so critical
and so fundamental to winning chess
games that it's worth a revisit and now
we have some new language to talk about
it we have the language of opposition
and outflanking
um if you want more details on Pawn
promotion just as an entity itself then
please check out some of the other
videos on that
but the basic idea is we're going to
need our King in front of our Pawn
because we need to get to a key Square
when you're trying to promote a pawn and
let's assume it's not a rook Pawn
because those your opponent can always
kind of guard
if it's any of these upon in any of
these more Central files
then we need our King in front of it
because we need our team to get to the
square that's basically a nice move in
front of the Pawn on these two squares
now why those matter well if you can
actually it can also be this one right
in front if you can get your king to any
of these three squares then there is
nothing black can do to stop us from
promoting the pawn and let me show you
what I mean so let's just step the king
forward
King E3 King E6
and King E4
so notice here how I've taken opposition
in this case black has to give it up
they have to move out of the way
but remember opposition is only a means
to an end I'm going to continue pressing
forward out flanking my opponent
allowing them to take opposition if they
want because the goal isn't now to you
know stop me from getting to a side of
the board their goal is to stop me from
being able to escort this Pawn to
promotion so they can't afford to play a
move like this I'm just going to push
the pawn forward
and I'm just going to keep marching up
so instead
they have to step back and you'll notice
this is a very similar pattern to what
we were looking at before we'll take
opposition
they have to pick a side whichever way
they go we can just step forward
if they go this way we'll step this way
now what is critical though is you might
be wondering okay well vectrift seems
like all you need to do is be in front
of the pawn so why did I say it has to
be these squares there's like a little
bit of breathing room right here kind of
a gap well the reason for that
is because if we're not careful if we
don't leave a gap say in this position I
play the move Pawn to E3 and now
black takes opposition and wait a minute
the three squares I needed to get to
right with one square in front of the
Palm
now black will always be able to stop me
from getting there they fully control
all of those squares
and without opposition I can't win this
end game
if my king is not able to stay in front
and here's what I mean so they they can
kind of just wall us off
eventually I'm either going to need to
move my King backwards or move my Pawn
forwards to try and make progress and I
can get my Pawn all the way to the end
of the board
the problem is at the very end there's a
very critical moment in this position
where it's black to move
black now has three legal moves our King
controls all of these squares our Pawn
controls these two
so the king can only go to d8 f8 or E8
and two of those moves lose one of them
draws
if you go to d8 or f8
you give us opposition
which is going to allow us to force your
king out of the way and we can promote
so instead the only drawing move here
for black is to play King back to E8
predicting that wherever I go
you will be able to then take opposition
and stop me for example King to F6 King
to f8 taking opposition I cannot make
forward progress with my king
so I pushed the pawn and you step in
front of it and now I am in zuk zwang
I have no moves that help me the best
move would be to pass
because
if I move my king to any square away
from my Pawn you will just take it and
it's a drop
If instead I move my king to E6 to
defend my Pawn the only Square I can
move that defends the pawn
it's a stalemate
because I control all of these squares
and black has no legal moves but it's
not in check
so that is why I need to keep both
opposition but also that's why you want
this one space of breathing room because
if I have this space of breathing room
let's change it a little bit
if black ever gets opposition
it's not the end of the world because as
long as I have at least one spare Square
in between I can always push the pawn
and basically regain opposition right
there is now an odd number of squares
and it's their turn to move so they have
to get out of the way and I can press
forward
uh I don't know how to pronounce your
name lapsis coastsenus but welcome we're
glad to have you here
okay so we talked about how to stop the
pawn but how do we actually finish our
job here so we're going to move the king
forward take opposition and out flank
meaning we can give them opposition if
they want it but they're not going to be
able to guard the key squares where
we're going to promote
so instead black steps back to stop us
we step over and we continue moving all
the way down to the edge of the board
and once you reach your king to the
sixth rank you don't have to worry about
opposition anymore we can just start
pushing the pawn
because this position is a win for white
regardless of whose move it is again if
you want more details on that please
check out the video on kind of I think
it's just called like something about
end games Beginning of the End Game or
something like that
um
but here if it's black to move then they
have to move out of the way and we will
step forward and promote the pawn
again out flanking if it is white to
move here so let's lose a move real
quick
so it's white to move now it doesn't
really matter because the timing still
works out where I can just push the pawn
and still get this relevant Square
okay
it is not possible to Castle vertically
only on the horizontals
okay so this is the basics of kind of
how to promote a pawn and we were able
to piece it together with understanding
how do we get our King to the key
squares right for the we always want to
be with one square between and to do
that we need to maintain both opposition
and out flanking whenever it is
appropriate
so let's take a look at this one because
we talked about how to win these games
but it's also how can we stop ourselves
from losing in this position it's white
to move
black has their King and pawn
dangerously close to the promotion ranks
if they can get their King to one of
these key squares then we can't stop
them from winning the game
the question is do we have any way to do
that
and we actually can if we think about
our ideas with opposition so white to
move how can we stop black from winning
this game
anyone have any ideas
if you had white here what would you
play
because we need to stop this Pawn from
promoting
Webster in the chat has the right move
King to C1
and let's think about this
if we move our King away it's quite
obvious that we cannot stop black from
getting to one of the key squares
they can just quickly Walk This Way and
we there their King is in front of the
pawn there's nothing we can do
if we step forward
then black can actually just take
opposition
and if we give them opposition then
eventually
they can force us to give it up they can
outflank and again push the pawn forward
so that's not going to work
and the same thing here if we step to C2
it's the same thing they will just take
opposition
and there's nothing we can do to stop
them
so the only move that is going to hold
the draw is King to C1
and this is actually really critical why
does this hold a draw it's because of
distant opposition
we have three squares in between
the Kings right now they're facing each
other with three squares in between
that's an odd number it's our opponents
starting to move when it's an odd number
of squares that means we have the
opposition
the problem for black is this if they
try and step forward
in any direction wherever they go we are
ready to meet them with opposition
if they go this way we can hold it this
way but you can also just move towards
the pawn with indirect opposition
if they step forward to C4
again we will just step to C2 opposition
you cannot make progress here
cannot keep the king in front of the
pawn
and if instead you go King to D4 it's
the exact same thing we just take
opposition if you have to push the pawn
well then we can go kind of wherever we
want as long as we can keep your king
from stepping to the key squares
so in a game like this it could be very
easy to lose it right in the very end
you've played a very strong game and you
just play the simple move King to C2 and
it's all over so the hope that I have
here is that we can help you avoid some
of those issues
let's look at one that's maybe a little
more confusing
it's white starting to move
and all I did was I shifted the king
from B1 to C1
can we still hold a draw or does this
simple placement issue mean that we are
going to lose
foreign
if you had white
so yeah I have two questions do you
think white can hold this and if so what
would the move be
remember our rules of opposition and how
we want to think about it
this is a tricky one
so someone says white can't hold
it certainly seems that way
someone's suggesting came to D1 okay
so let's think about this
from B1 to C1 we have all the same
problems that we had before
if we had stepped forward in that
example then we will be met with
opposition if we step forward in this
example to any of these squares our
opponent has distant opposition right
there's an odd number of squares between
the two kings and if we move forward
then we're the one moving with the odd
number
they have opposition
King B2 does not work because again
first they're going to take opposition
if they want it
but they can also take indirect
opposition and just come this way to
help the pawn get home
so we can't move forward at all what
they just have us covered
however if we go to D1
fascinatingly this is a draw
for a very specific reason
black would love to play the move King
to D5 and maintain this oppositional
advantage
but there's a pawn there
so you can't do it
and any other move we can start to cut
you off from the key squares if we can
keep you from getting to any of these
three squares we can win this game
if this King steps forward it's very
easy
and if the Kinks have sword here it's
the same thing we don't go forward to D2
giving them opposition we go King to C2
maintaining the opposition and again
there's no way for black to make
progress we will copy them wherever they
go and get our key in front of the pawn
so this is actually the only way to win
this one it's kind of or not win but to
hold a draw which when you're down a
pawn and there's nothing else on the
board that's pretty we should be pretty
happy with that result
okay let's do another exercise uh one of
my friends here at the chess club uh
National Master Caleb Denby if you have
seen any of his lectures uh did a really
fun puzzle
where in this example it's white to move
and here's the the problem with this
specific puzzle now if you know the king
and Rook end game it's pretty easy to
win but here's the trick
it's white to move and when
but you can only move the Rook one time
which means
you're going to need to move the Rook to
get checkmate so unless you are moving
The Rook with Checkmate The Rook is not
allowed to move can we do it
can we force black into a Checkmate even
if we only get to move the Rook once
what should we do what should our idea
be
okay
foreign
that's awesome I never saw this until
just recently so
I think it's really cool
but it totally plays into our
oppositional idea yeah yeah Richard
we're gonna shoulder the king basically
all the way back so the first thing we
need to do is take opposition
right this is kind of the central thing
here and what's critical is because our
Rook is attacking everything in this
line
uh the king this King can never step in
that direction you can't move into check
so we never have to worry about that we
can effectively treat this whole line as
an edge of the board that is off limits
to Black's King
so when we take opposition black is
limited to three moves
you can move to H3 H4 or G4
if if King goes to G4
how do we maintain opposition we just
follow him forward
and we can do this all the way to the
end of the board
until
it's a checkmate
okay what else can you try
if you go to H4
then we can also do the same thing we
can maintain opposition
if you go backwards we're just going to
follow you if you go again backwards
diagonally we're just going to follow
you and we can force a Checkmate this
way as long as we have maintained
opposition
we can force checkmate with only moving
The Rook one time
so the tricky one here is after King to
G1 what if I play King to H3 because now
if you maintain opposition which is fine
you can do that I'm just going to go
back and we're going to start repeating
moves you're not going to make any
progress so how do you make progress
here
yes precisely I don't know how to
pronounce her name in the chat but King
to F2 this is our outflanking maneuver
right it's the same thing when they have
when we have opposition the benefit is
we can either stop someone from making
progress towards us or we can outflank
to reach a critical Square
in this case the problem is
now black has a tough choice
if they go well let's look at their
options now their options are still
three moves now they can go to H2
H4 or G4
if they go to
G4 then we're just going to repeat what
we just did we're going to retake
opposition and they have these same
three moves as before but we're either
going to follow them back follow them
diagonally back or if they go to H4
we're just going to repeat what we just
did out flank
If instead they play King to H2
then now they're in a zuk Swang of a
different kind because now we step to F3
and when they play up the only move
well now they have taken opposition
successfully but that actually means
that our King is cutting them off and
this is a checkmate
and this is going to be true at every
instance of it in the game so say they
play G4 and then they go
H3 it's the same thing you can't go down
this way because it's a checkmate
if you go to H5 taking indirect
opposition
what should we do here
you have to be very careful
so I have a few things so someone's
saying F4 someone's saying G3 someone's
saying G2
so we seem really divided on this one
think about it
um
kind of oppositionally
if we play King to G2
can black take opposition
yes
which means if they get the opposition
there is no way to complete this puzzle
we're going to have to use the Rook for
more than that because they can just
stall us out forever
if we play King to G3 it's the same
thing
so instead of allowing them to take
opposition in that way the only way
we're comfortable with them taking
opposition is here
where we can eventually get a checkmate
so we just continue we'll move to King
to F4 and notice how this actually just
repeats with a position before
we go to F3 and we have this kind of
awkward
outflanking maneuver where they're
trying to take opposition but shouldn't
if they step back we just repeat it and
give them the same choices they can
either step forward and get checkmated
or they can step backwards
and allow us to if they step here we
take opposition
and if they step here we just continue
to repeat
all the way to the end of the board
so a very simple puzzle right just three
pieces and one arbitrary rule we can't
move the Rook until it's checkmate
and even then we can still Force the
king to move exactly how we want because
of our use of these two techniques
opposition and out flanking when you put
them together it's an incredibly deadly
and Incredibly powerful force I want to
show you uh three more examples that
kind of all highlight this idea someone
was asking for some more distant
opposition examples
and I hope this will partially suffice
so this is our position
and I believe it's white to move
and we're playing from the black side
here
do we have any hope in this position
of winning or at least drawing what do
we think
is this a win for whites a win for black
or a draw
the hint I will give you is not really a
hint it's just telling you it's
absolutely not us to win because we have
no way to move our pawns forward safely
they're just going to get captured
and White's King is closer White's King
has effectively become more active and
is going to box us out and Gobble up
these pawns and there's actually nothing
we can do about it
so we cannot win we're going to lose
both of our pawns whether we push them
or whether we don't this King and pawns
are going to be able to eat all of our
Pawns
so we can't win the question is can we
draw or not
and actually even though some people
might look at this position and say it
feels like we can just resign here
because we can't stop these two pawns
there is a way to hold a draw as plaque
if we keep our ideas in mind
so let's start by just walking towards
those squares
but eventually I mean you can even play
King E8 here but eventually we have a
really tricky move
again the theme Here is not so much the
pawns it is The Kinks but actually we
can play H5
and force white into a really awkward
spot of making a rook pond because if
they choose to make a rook Pawn they
actually have two Rook ponds and if we
can get our Kinks snuggled up into the
corner they actually cannot stop us from
uh they cannot do anything to force us
out of it
so King to E8
and if they just keep running the pawn
forward we'll catch it this way
if they move the king then again we can
hide our King on the corner and even
though they have two pawns because they
are both Rook pawns we can just bounce
our King back and forth between these
three squares for the rest of the game
and there's actually no way to out flank
right because out flanking or even
taking opposition doesn't really matter
anymore because you cannot out Flank In
this direction right the board ends
so that's why the corner pawns are
different
okay but let's look if we do something
else so they don't have to take they
don't want to take the Rook pond
so instead let's say they defend their
Pawn
yeah what if so good question from
insane lonely bear I love that username
so if they just play H3 and defend right
how do we do anything here
well now we can trade Pawns
and take opposition
remember even though we can't save our
Pawn
if white can manage to get to one of
these three squares after their Pawn is
gone they'll win if we can keep them
from getting to any of those key squares
we can hold a draw
and here White's in zuk Swang if they
take our Pawn
we take opposition even though they have
the extra Pawn they cannot get to the
square they need to and the game is a
draw
if they don't take our Pawn
we can just wait them out
we'll either repeat moves or eventually
they will give up and take the pawn and
it's a draw
so even in some crazy positions like
this if you can remember the ideas of
opposition in this case you have to have
a little knowledge of Rook pawns and
maybe the rule of the square but if you
can keep those in mind
we can still hold draws in these
positions just by using our King in a
very strategic way with opposition
all right here's our next example
in this position it's white to move and
we're going to be playing from the white
side
our pawns are moving this way these
pawns are moving this way so they're all
locked up
and it seems like this should be a draw
it's totally even the kings are
equidistant
basically from the pawns so it seems
like this should be a draw
but white actually has a way to win
first thing we need to do is we can't
actually break through with any of these
Pawns we have to recognize that if we
try and push upon then they can just
take it and we're not going to be able
to catch up in time
so we cannot ever push those pawns at
least until the Kings are close enough
so both sides are going to kind of scoot
the Kings to get a little bit closer
and now we enter this position
and the question is how can white manage
to win this it seems like this should be
over
but there actually is a way
to force a win and not let the game just
end up in a draw
what should we do in this position
and keep the ideas of opposition in mind
outflanking as well but I think this one
is a little bit more about opposition
and if you have ideas you're free to to
ask and we can kind of talk about them
foreign
suggesting uh G5 I think you mean King
to G5
definitely an idea there take on G6
another idea
lots of competition well let's think
about this in terms of opposition of
someone yes okay so 17 and a few other
people actually multiple people have
found the right idea the first thing we
want to do is take on G6 if we play King
to G5 we actually end up in a really bad
spot and we'll see why in just a moment
if we take on G6
after they take now what do we do
now if we take either Pawn they will
take the other one and this should be a
draw
they can attack our Pawn but we can
attack theirs and we're both going to be
able to promote
and the same is true if he takes the
other way
so instead King to G5 taking opposition
and whichever way I go you will follow
me with opposition but also take my Pawn
and now you just have a past Pawn if I
go attack this one you can still defend
it
and there's nothing I can do to stop
this Pawn from promotion
if I had instead played King to G5
myself then now black gets that exact
same thing they can take with opposition
and after we take they follow us with
opposition and they will take either one
so even in these really kind of uh
coordinated or balanced positions that
look like they're going to be draws if
we can remember opposition and just how
critical it can be to be able to be the
one to force your opponent to concede
space it can make all the difference
let's look at one final example
this one is this is honestly I don't
think a beginner level puzzle it's not
exactly Advanced
um but it's going to combine all the
ideas of opposition and outflanking
together
and I think it's still going to be very
instructive for us to look at so in this
position it's white to move
black has a rook Pawn here on A5 and
their King is far away on f8 but
they are very skilled our opponent here
with the black pieces is very skilled in
the ideas of opposition and if we don't
play carefully they will force their
King in front of our pawn and deny us
getting to one of these key squares
um first of all if they can just get
their King close enough
and keep a Pawn on the board it's just
going to be an easy draw because neither
of us can push the pawn forward and even
if we do then whoever loses it is still
not going to be able to get their King
in front of the pawn
so we have to be very careful here with
how we play
the first move is a little more uh
natural we want to start this with King
to C2
if we play too slowly like King to B1
then black can just very easily move
their King forward
and actually just defend their Pawn
right now even if we can trade the pawns
and it's going to be dead equal but even
if they just give up the pawn for some
reason this still is not a win
um I suppose if we take it this way that
would be so again they got to be careful
with giving us too much opposition but
if they know what they're doing
if they go probably here
now even then well yeah they can take
so anyway they don't even have to play
precisely but if they get their King
super close to our Pawn then it's yeah
basically over
so instead uh
yes yes
insane lonely Bear yes you spotted it
slightly before I did so King C2 instead
and now black plays a really tricky move
instead of moving their King forward
they're going to play Pawn to A4
if they bring their King forward
then the problem is we're just too fast
we get this pawn and we can still get to
one of these key squares very easily
our King is far ahead of the pawn but
not too far where we can't defend it so
we're going to be able to easily win
this end game
so instead they play A4 cutting us off
we now cannot move to B3 which is a bit
of a problem
this is the really critical position of
this example and it's kind of the last
puzzle I will leave you with maybe one
more move
but it is white to move
and there's only one way to do this
this is very very tough
does anyone have any idea for how we can
make progress as lights
okay King D2 suggested
King B2 well our Pawn is on B2 King D3
King B1
yes a lot of people have the right idea
but 17 said the precise reason we need
to play King to be one that's the only
move because otherwise black plays A3 if
we play something like King to C3
A3 kind of destroys us
if we don't move the pawn they will take
it
if we take their Pawn then we now have a
rook pawn and again they're just going
to get their King in front of our Rook
pawn and we can't win
so we have to play B3
but now they can slowly move forward if
we move our King this way to attack
their Pawn they're just going to sneak
through and promote
but as long as their Pawn doesn't move
they're guarding this Square so
something like King to E7
and say we play Pawn to B4 they'll just
force us back to stop their pawn and
their King is close enough to keep us
from getting ahead
If instead of B4 we play something like
King to C2 then again their King is just
going to be able to stop us and even if
we can stop their Pawn they're still at
the very least going to be ahead of us
so instead we have to play King to B1
where now if they play A3
we can scoop past with B3 and we're one
move closer
King to E7 King to A2 and we effectively
reach the key square of A5 a very hard
example uh if they go this way we take
opposition and then again they will have
to concede one of these two squares
really kind of crazy example not
something I would expect to come up in
one of your games too often but
hopefully these ideas have been helpful
for you in just understanding the basics
of how the king should work in the end
game especially against your opponent's
king these two ideas outflanking on
opposition really you can dig into these
for a very long time and they will
continue to give you lots of help in
your chess that is all the time we have
for tonight but I hope you have enjoyed
this lesson and I hope you stick around
because I believe we have our
grandmaster's choice class with our new
Grandmaster who I forget who it is
Josh Shang super excited we're super
glad to have him so please stick around
for that I hope to see you soon
[Music]